welcome back to the show what is a woman
can you believe we're asking it but the
question has perhaps worryingly
dominated political debate in the last
few years it's certainly a question that
can be used to entrap politicians around
the globe leaders we've seen them
squirming from head to toe let's just
say some answer the question where these
others really don't
to be honest Sean that's that questions
come slightly out of left field for me
um
people Define themselves people to find
their own genders like trans women are
women but in the present context there
is no automatic right for a trans woman
in our context where our trans women is
not a woman no there is there is
circumstances in which a trans woman
will be housed in the male prison estate
look I'm not
I don't think we can conduct this
debate with
no no
I just yeah I of course I know a woman
who adult human female
well this week Britain's prime minister
Richie soon at you just saw him at the
end there when he was speaking to Piers
Morgan a few weeks ago he has pledged to
change the equality act here in the UK
to introduce legal protections for
biological women in same-sex spaces with
the move perhaps Banning trans women
from accessing Single Sex spaces is it
fair that's our question coming up now
joining me is transgender teacher and
journalist Debbie Hayton and Freda
Wallace from the Manchester LGBT
Foundation great to have you both with
us on this important issue
um you know what uh seeing that New
Zealand leader there saying this
question is coming out of left field
that strikes me because it's really not
left field at the moment this is
absolutely mainstream debate and let's
just start with the very obvious change
that's being preserved proposed by the
conservative government here in the UK
at the moment uh Debbie I'll come to you
first is it a sensible move
I do think it's a sensible move uh trans
people have been let down badly in the
same way women have been let down badly
by badly uh worded laws that have
increasingly been based on feelings and
that's no basis of anybody's rights
trying to base those laws on feelings
has led to uncertainty it's led to
confusion and a lack of confidence in
the law we need to get back to reality
let's pose that then to Freda about the
feelings point because what's the core
of this is changing the legal definition
legal protections for people depending
on their biological sex is what's
proposed rather than legal sex so what
do you make of Debbie's point there do
you think this is the sensible move
no it's not about feelings it's about
social reality and the way people
conduct the cells in social lives you
know like I you know no nobody cares how
I identify they just accept me as I am
you know and in my social life and my
real life the female friends I know the
CIS female friends I know don't have a
problem this is just it's political
maneuvering really and it's completely
unworkable I've had like distressed
emails today from trans women trans
young trans people actually that they're
worried that they're not going to be
able to live their lives they're not
going to be able to go into the toilets
that they always would have but it's
it's just a ridiculous scenario it's not
going to happen I would like to reassure
trans people out there that is
completely unworkable because for to to
please this you would have to check
people you know are you going to check
whether somebody's male or female in a
public space it's just not workable it's
not realistic there is I see your point
there about the realisticness of it the
the common sense side of it how it's
actually going to be enforced but do you
accept um Frida the reason this is being
brought up and the reason the government
is pushing hard for it is because there
have been a couple of cases and I
appreciate their small of Bad actors
that are kind of messing it up for the
rest
we feel unsafe we don't base laws based
on Bad actors that mess it up for the
rest there were there were seven women
convicted just today of sex crimes you
know it's got nothing to do with whether
you're trans or not whether you're a
perpetrator of heinous crimes they
always try and make out that you know
trans women as some kind of threat
you'll hear people like Helen Joyce
completely misinterpretting this all the
time it's just not our reality works I'm
afraid and it's like I was hoping that
Kelly J Keane was going to be on this
show tonight because she is somebody
that is like complete a totally
ridiculous person that's followed around
the world by the far right and it's like
this is that this is the level of
ridiculousness this uh this debate has
got to now and it's uh you know it's
just she she was invited she wasn't able
to be here so she isn't able because
she's chickened out the ridiculous
person
well she is you know she's she's
somebody that traveled 11 000 miles to
get covered in soup and then came back
and claimed it was some kind of Victory
on this point because uh and I will come
back to
um very shortly Debbie but I just want
to come back to Frida on this because
the the way this conversation is going
you brought up some real concrete
examples there of you know emails you've
received today real life examples of
Trans women who are being impacted by
this decision but then starting to slam
people by calling them ridiculous isn't
this the kind of route that we go down
where this debate becomes so toxic so
aggressive and it actually undoes the
cause
I don't think so I think when you when
you're actually followed by the like if
you're followed by an organization
organization called Arts of Hulk Who
Tommy Robinson founded be followed by
those kind of people you deserve to have
everything thrown at you including soup
sorry that's just how it is I do
appreciate there is toxicity on both
sides of the debate look Debbie coming
back to you in terms of the way uh that
we have it feels like reached a Tipping
Point in this issue
um whereas a few years ago we've come
light years uh from you know people
being accused of being turfs obviously
that is a real and concrete concern uh
but also people wanting to speak up
about their own delicate issues
surrounding rights and women's rights as
well so talk to me about what you're
seeing where we are along that Tipping
Point when it comes to trans rights but
also defending the rights of women
well we're in a position where trans
rights were as I said dependent on
feelings we made an assertion and
everybody just believed us uh now the
boot seems to be on the other foot women
are ex women are asserting their
feelings unrightly so uh but feelings
are not a basis of law we need to come
back to reality uh we need to respect
women and women's versus if you know if
we uh if we claim to identify with women
then we should respect their species we
shouldn't go uh and take those verses
from them and uh talking about young
trans people I just regret that the uh
the false promises that have been made
young people have been told that they
can change sex or they can be the
opposite sex I can tell you as a science
teacher it's just not true and the
problem is that young people have been
made promises that nobody can uh nobody
can keep and it's not the best is to go
forwards we need to come back to reality
we need to come back to science and we
need to base laws on what we can measure
and what we can see which is biological
sex and and just stay with you for a
second Debbie because there's some I
want to ask you if you think you see any
issues with this proposed government
change the equality act because there
are some interesting points one being
brought up by the uh a quality Watchdog
to the government saying this changed so
the ACT could actually make it easier
for Trans men to bring pay
discrimination cases because they'll be
judged on their biological sex which was
woman
um it's definitely tricky ground to
tread do you see any kind of
complications coming along if it is if
it is enforced
well we need we need a property book we
need to listen to each other and we need
to talk but by removing laws back to
what is objective what is concrete and
what is real is the best is to be moving
forwards and you you're quite right to
point out about trans men there's also
the issue about it as it stands trans
men find it very difficult to uh uh to
uh exert the rights under a pregnancy
and maternity because the where the law
is written and it's because of think
issues like this that we need to come
back and we need to just analyze what
the law is actually there for and how we
can best apply it I'm glad you brought
up the issue of trans men there as well
or in their cause because it this law
would apply to both trans men and trans
women when it comes to this idea of
biological sex points and the legal
protections of those uh Freda back to
you if I can because
Debbie was making the point there that
as a trans woman she would like to be on
the side of women and understand where
they're coming in at this debate so talk
to me from the point of view of your
organization and the activism you do
where women fit into that
well we we include all women from all
walks of life and there are so many
diverse types of women and it's like I
just don't understand what Debbie is
waffling on about she's represent she
represents an organization called the
LGB Alliance but actually don't like
Debbie at all they pretend to an
investigation by Ben Hunt Vice magazine
revealed them to been like in tampering
with the ehrc the actual laws that you
know that you're talking about now it's
a it's total corruption that's going on
and it plays into the hands of people
like Lee Anderson who's already saying
that he'll use this issue for the next
election since people are being used as
a political football and Debbie I mean
does Debbie identify as a woman is she
Mr Debbie I don't know how she conducts
herself in social life but it's not
realistic is it in any sense the Debbie
to identify as a woman and then say she
shouldn't be allowed in female spaces
Freda I mean I'm taking issue with the
way some of these personal attacks are
being directed Debbie but I'm going to
allow Debbie to respond
uh can I just say that I don't represent
the LGB Alliance at all that that's
that's that's just not true and I I go
about my life as Debbie I uh I I you
know this this is this is this is this
is not an issue I don't identify as a
woman you know women or female
I'm Dr Debbie so you're Mr Debbie you're
not Mrs Mrs Debbie Hayton no I'm Dr
Debbie Hayden so I said so but doctor
doesn't uh the sex delineation is it
oh so who are you
Daddy are you missed are you Mr Debbie
Hayton
uh why why is this an issue why is this
an issue because it's important because
this is this is the delineation we have
in society if you're gonna start calling
yourself Mr Debbie you're going to have
a lot of problems there accessing female
spaces or even male spaces
I I don't access female Space versus
Freedom it be wrong for us those are for
women
you're a ridiculous per you don't
represent anything Debbie be realistic I
I want to end this conversation here
because uh I don't actually I think it's
very nice
um the personal tax that we've had on
Debbie this evening I want to thank you
Debbie for sharing your experience with
us I'm not taking either side in the
debate but Frieda when we take into
context what is being done to try and
fight for Trans rights at the moment and
for the rights of women it's a toxicity
of this type of debate that seems to be
holding everything back but I want to
thank you both your insights this
evening we're gonna wrap things up there
Freedom W thanks so much